[Music]
daniel kicks us off in tampa daniel
welcome to the show
hey there thank you for taking the call
and i appreciate it george and christina
thank you for all you do for everyone
great so uh my wife and i are currently
in step two now we kind of discovered
the whole baby steps a little later in
life we already had some retirements set
aside um but here's the question um
comparables in the area are running for
about 660 for our house
we currently owe 325.
um we do have a growing tent well i
would say we have
a family and i think we're outgrowing
the size of our home so ideally we'd
like to be in a five-bedroom home or so
so those are running for about 8.50 in
the area wow um
so so here's my question we we bought
the home just before the spike so
we owe about 325 on it currently we have
a good amount of equity if we're able to
to sell that and of course that'll
kick-start us from step two straight on
to
you know the next i believe step four at
that point
um my question is is that is that a good
approach should we sell our current home
use the equity to buy a bigger home and
get us out of
you know the existing step two
it can be now when you say buy a bigger
home it means we're going possibly
further into debt so it's not
necessarily a the best move right but i
do love i mean people make sacrifices
all the time to get out of debt and one
of those things is we're willing to sell
the home take the equity pay off the
debt and whatever's left we then move on
and go all right what can we afford now
so what's the home worth if you sold it
today
it would be about 650
650 and you owe 325.
how big is your family you said you
needed to um upgrade get a little bit
more space
yeah so we my estimate both work from
home we have three kids it's a three
to three two currently
um so it's a little tight okay what's
your income
it's 140 combined
and how much debt do you have
um so we've got a van
about 20k on the van and i think i'm not
mistaken another 12 or so on credit
cards
and that's all the debt except for that
325 mortgage
correct that's it and we do have some
retirement i would say combined probably
close to the 100 000 range
okay are you guys currently investing
yes okay
well you may not like my advice but it
is to pause investing while we pay off
the debt now if you're selling the house
tomorrow and this is all going down you
may not have to do that but uh following
the ramsey plan it's countercultural
it's weird and we focus on one thing at
a time so that we actually make some
progress and looking at the numbers here
it doesn't give me a lot of confidence
because if you sold for you know you
said 650 you may net
less than 300 then we still have to pay
off 30 grand of debt leaving us with
about 270. you tracking
so 270 down on an 850 000 home you're
talking almost 600 000 in mortgage which
is gonna double your mortgage payment
which doesn't put you guys in a great
spot financially even though you're
debt-free
sure and so yeah
i think we need to pause or we go to a
maybe a lateral house that has more room
that may be a little further out you
know you may have to make some
compromises here and kind of reset the
expectations of what home is next
sure sure and for what it's worth in the
event that we do sell today and say we
we sit on
you know there's a gap of six months or
so we do have a place to live you know
my folks were kind enough to extend an
invitation to house our family until we
do find that bigger home so sort of
county on that but that's probably a six
month margin
but even then you're not gonna get
you're still gonna have over a half
million dollar mortgage
right
yeah and i love i love that you have the
desire to pay off the baby step to debt
i love that you want to get rid of that
van i love that you want to get rid of
the credit card and if you are selling
your current house to downgrade and
create more margin where you could pay
off that debt and then not increase debt
in another area i'd be all for it but i
think just that makes me nervous going
up so much in-house and like george said
having such a big mortgage following
that that's just kind of like a little
bit nerve-wracking i think especially
with having three kids um it just feels
a little bit nerve-wracking if i were in
your shoes what's your take-home pay
every month
one day
is that 60 1600 okay because i'm looking
at the numbers here and uh if you did a
15-year fixed rate mortgage which is the
only mortgage i'm gonna tell you to get
and you put 270 down on an 850 000 house
in this market your
monthly payment is 5 500
you guys won't be able to eat
yeah and so even six months of saving
even while living with the parents it's
not going to change the numbers
drastically enough to make this a wise
financial move so what that tells me is
this you make 140 you've got 30 in debt
we can pay off the debt and stay in the
home for now and you said you feel like
we're running out of space we might have
to get a little bit creative right now
and see if we can squeeze out another
year
living here until we make a move and
again it may be a more of a lateral move
we may only get a four bedroom instead
of a five and we make that work
how many kids do you have
three
okay can either of them share a bedroom
they currently do okay true
are they miserable do they feel like
they're in a prison
no we are no you are it's the parents of
course
yeah another
they're great
well you guys are you're on the right
path what's the van worth
and
uh well i i know that we owe 20k i i
haven't done numbers as far as what it's
worth i do have a paid off vehicle
that's about
just about the same it's it's definitely
worth about the same okay and you need
the two cars right you got to haul the
kids around is that what the vans for
yeah just you know in the event that one
breaks down we do have the backup means
of transportation but you only need one
car
i would say we do just need one because
you know we
we do both work from home
okay
well i'm just wondering if the van's
worth you know 30 and we you owe 20 on
it that gives you a net of 10 and you
almost clean up the credit card debt and
we're debt-free by tomorrow and then we
can start stacking up cash uh to make
this home move
that's an option now you may need the
van or you you know but i'm just looking
at the options here going if you don't
only need one car you both work from
home the kids can fit in the other car
for now if one breaks down you have an
emergency fund right
you're right
so we're good we'll go fix it up we'll
go get another car whatever we have to
do to get back on the road but that's
one way to clean this mess up now i
don't know the worth of the vehicle so
that's your homework assignment is to
look into that and figure out is this
worth selling there's no need to it's
not a huge part of your financial world
but if you're itching to get out of debt
fast i would do that way before i would
think about selling the house
way less of a hassle sure
okay so that's the move man i'm pulling
for you that's tough three kids you got
some debt we want to upgrade the house
but it's gonna have to wait and the kids
they won't remember it they're just
gonna remember the awesome childhood
they had sharing a bedroom right yeah
and you'll get there this is only for a
season you will get there you'll get
that bigger house have a little space
and room to breathe we're going to do it
the right way and move at the speed of
cash pay off the debt and do it with
wisdom thanks for the call man